New York Queens so rough pour over hey
Tom are you talking to no one
just making a little video of the trip
you know you can't show it to anyone
yeah the way narrating in that voice oh
this one fine
so uh what'd they call you happy come on
I'm not carrying your bags go hey should
I go to the bathroom before there's a
bathroom on it
whoa no pilot that's awesome very gonna
sit yeah is your first time on a private
plane or so on anything
should it be we should every weekend
away
no one has actually told me why I'm in
brewing or what I'm doing something
about Captain America going crazy this
is you how were neighbors we're not
roommates yeah okay there you got this -
god what the hell are you wearing a suit
where's the case okay that's not much
what I thought that was a closet
this is Sylmar vote please my room is
way bigger than up here I found a case I
found a case around it a minor upgrade
Oh
oh my god put it on put it like this is
the coolest thing ever
let's go yeah I don't understand is it
for me happy happy wait this is insane
insane look at this thing look look at
the I sister great day my life okay okay
okay Captain America Iron Man Black
Widow
Wow who's that new girlfriend Betty I
gotta go a guy go everyone okay so the
craziest thing just happened right
my terrified with Captain America and I
stole his shield not threw it at him at
him
hi he's big now I gotta go she was those
amazing thing is never misses over here
ruse and I just sort of flipped in and I
stole cap she lies I can't even jump
everybody and it hey check the second
coming hey listen walls here ladies a
little video diary yeah sorry I tried
telling not to do it he was filming
everything I'm gonna run away chip hey
you know what we should actually we
should make an alibi video for your
hands
anyways ready how about like Jim gets
afraid hey how you doing what do you
wearing something skimpy I hope to give
that bit appropriate all right let's
start over you can edit it is it 3-1 hey
May my gosh I want to tell you what a
incredible job
your nephew did this weekend at the
stark internship retreat
everyone was impressed come on
it's a frigging merge this because
you're not in Queens Boulevard see
happiest is hoping to get bumped up to
asset management he was for head of
security and for that it was just a
driver private conversation
I don't like joking about this it was
hard for me to talk to you
no seriously was a snore no but all
right here we are whoops happy can you
give us a moment you will meet a real
rap Peters case out of the trunk I can
keep this shoot yes we were just talking
about do me a favor though
Happy's kind of your point guy on this
dust stress amount don't do anything
stupid
I've seen his cardiogram all right yes
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate what does that
mean I'm gonna VIN tomorrow is it
seventh floor
I need to go you don't have to do you're
gonna take it I can take thank you
she wins wins her next step was only
retreat you know what next mission yeah
in the mission the missions will call
you you have my numbers no I mean we'll
call you like someone will call you Oh
all right fatigue there's not a hug and
just grabbing the door for you we're not
we're not there yet
bye
everybody bit up a surprise but they
dropped the spider-man prequel movie
online so I'll do a breakdown but I'm
also naming a new giveaway winner at the
end of this so there's only a couple
problems that I have with this and I'll
explain it's nothing to do with the
characters I love Tom Holland in the
movie I've already done my review so
I'll post a link to that at the end of
this because hopefully you're all seeing
it this week but it's basically Peter
Parker filming his whole retreat with
the Avengers as he describes it with
Iron Man and then later at the end of
this getting the actual suit you mean I
get to keep it good luck kid there's a
little gray area in the middle there
that's where you operate that's where a
friendly neighborhood spider-man exists
but if you've ever lived in New York
you'll spot Flushing Meadows Park
instantly because of that big globe but
in the Marvel Universe that's where the
stark Expo was so it's a big Easter Egg
for that and I know you've all been
asking me about that Iron Man 2 Easter
Egg they revealed I thought about doing
a video for it but I just never got
around to it basically they're saying
that the little kid in Iron Man 2
wearing the mask was actually Peter
Parker Tom Holland kind of made it up on
the spot and then Kevin Feige just
backed him up and said yeah yeah that
was totally you so that's one way to add
Easter eggs to pre-existing films they
just canonized it as Peter Parker
because he grew up in Queens so it makes
sense that he would have gone to that
big stark Expo when that was happening
but they also used this to set up the
relationship between happy and Peter and
I love Happy's relationship with Iron
Man he spent the last 30 seconds making
fun of them Happy's been working in
security he feels underappreciated he
wants to be an asset management so it
sort of sets up the relationship between
happy Iron Man and Peter during
spider-man homecoming without any real
big spoilers like none of this is stuff
that you haven't seen before so I
actually feel like it's a good way to
market the film but I don't know about
the first-person perspective like the
selfie cam that gets a little bit crazy
but I do love the way when he's in that
airport battle how he puts the phone
down so it captures all this background
action and they cut that in so obviously
they didn't go back and film a lot of
this Airport battle they just cut scenes
from that into this but even if the
selfie cam is a little bit much for you
I would like to see more Marvel unboxing
videos characters unboxing new presence
that Tony gives to them like imagine
Christmas comes and he gives Kap a new
version of his shield you see Steve
ripping through
the wrapping paper oh my god this is so
amazing but you really get that vibe at
the end of this that Iron Man is more of
his big brother and that's kind of how
Tony thinks about it even though he
cares about Peter deeply and Robert
Downey jr. 'he's talked a little bit
about how he played it during the movie
like he doesn't think of him as a son
he's not going to adopt Peter even
though he's emotionally adopted him he
remembers his tragic childhood how he
grew up so fast and he wants Peter to be
able to have a real childhood he doesn't
want him to get broken down by the world
like Iron Man was before he climbed out
of that cave but you have to remember
that Tony and Peter share a lot in
common they both lost their parents when
they were very young
they're both science geeks so Ironman
wants to take him under his wing but
this movie is sort of like a tryout for
the Avengers so like they say at the end
of this he gets to be the handler for
Peter Parker even though happy doesn't
want to have anything to do with them so
it's pretty simple I think it's a good
piece of bonus content and Tom Holland
did say that he wanted to do more Marvel
one-shots so that's really kind of what
it is it's kind of a Marvel one-shot
that just bridges the gap so they don't
have to deal with this during the actual
homecoming movie but let me know in the
comments they do another Marvel one-shot
with the spider-man character what do
you want that to be now a lot of you
might not have seen homecoming yet so
when you've seen homecoming let me know
what you want that one shot to be
because they typically focus on
underserved characters like Agent
Coulson or they do to please the fandom
when there was the big furor over the
Mandarin character how dare you pervert
the mandarins origin story so they shot
a real film just to let you know that
there's a real Mandarin out there
somewhere whether or not we ever
actually get to see him in a movie but
leave all your spider-man video requests
in the comments below
I'll post Easter eggs and post credits
at the end of the week but the big news
is that the flash just started shooting
today Daniel Pennebaker posted this
picture it begins so new flash probably
some new Rick and Morty tomorrow too and
I'll say happy fourth of July weekend
even if you don't celebrate it and you
live outside the United States everybody
be sure and have some fun if I don't get
it up in time then that flash video will
just post on Tuesday morning
congratulations to Marvel nerd 2015
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for that
spider-man review and you can click here
for new Thor
magna Rock and to learn about what's
going on with Marvel's comic-con
presentation thank you so much for
watching everybody is based awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you